do you know what Rotten Tomatoes is love
Rotten Tomatoes it's a rating site the
best place to get ratings for movies I
look at it pretty frequently I don't
think they would taste very good
we're we're off to a start
[Music]
absolutely have all right and what's
that web address rottentomatoes.com
you're one for one baby
you guys to rate most of my movies a
place I trust implicitly to decide if
I'm gonna watch a movie or not I trust
Rotten Tomatoes more than expensive IMDb
I think it's a place we go to review
bomb
how about new you are a review
aggregator site a review aggregation
site it shows the average other
reviewers from critics and audiences to
see if you might like or dislike a movie
collects movie reviews from all the
critics who are verified and then gives
that a percentage of what critics think
is good or not there's a critics score
and an audience score critics post their
reviews and then the audience score
comes in and there's like a generalized
report that comes in from like whatever
the movie is did you study for this
that's really good no I did not read
what other people say about a movie and
then you decide whether or not it's good
you don't make an opinion for yourself
well you can use it to inform your own
opinion if you'd like that's not the
experience I've had
[Music]
I actually don't but I'm assuming
there's an analytical metric system that
they use I am sorry I'm not from this
planet isn't it how people rate
different movies it says if it sucks or
not I'd imagine the more Tomatoes The
Better tomato eater is how they're
ranked rottens are bad and uh fresh are
really good a certain amount of good
reviews gets you a fresh rating and a
certain number of bad ones gets your
rotten rating
I like this one it's a culmination of
reviews of collective body of people who
are certified as Rotten Tomato critics
and then the meters basically someone
gives a fresh or rotten because you get
an average of what that movie is by all
the reviews on there side of like 20
reviews 18 or positive two are negative
you're really good at this yeah so
overall after you actually have the
overall percentage if most people give
it fresh and you have a higher
percentage koi johndro can you tell me
what the Tomato Meter is the Tomato
Meter is an aggregate system to gather
lots and lots of data and put it in a
black and white scale so a pass fail but
what it actually is is a series of
reviews that go from a one to five scale
and if it tips past a certain point it
is either positive or negative so it's
Gathering a lot of positive and negative
data and turning it into a yes no so
it's a lot more complex than just rotten
or fresh but people don't think about it
that way I love doing a beautiful mind
foreign
[Music]
oh 75 that's certified fresh oh my gosh
it needs to be 50 tile
79 98. 98 I believe it's like 60 and
above it is 60 and above congratulations
69 percent
great number but we're just looking for
60 or above you're so you're flirting
with correctness that's what you need
the average lips needs to be I mean you
still get a degree with a d average
barely barely listen trust me I'm a guy
that got a lot of D minuses and look at
how I ended up
is 60 too low I I thought it'd be hard I
thought at least be 75 and no lower than
that I mean if a movie gets a D minus it
still passes right yikes
[Music]
audience over critics I think the
audience I like the audience the
audience always audience I would say the
audience audience I trust the audience
score more America
the audience always how do you feel
about the critic
[Music]
I might not be on the same level as them
I feel like audience are a little bit
more down to earth I'm into the
entertainment which is what the audience
is critics guy critics most of the time
sometimes the audience doesn't really
know what they're talking about critics
because the audience is mostly made up
of idiots so guys both I go with a
little bit of both I try to kind of
gauge both I usually a splattering of
both critics are sort of mean okay and
some fans are stupid
[Laughter]
sometimes the critics are all right but
sometimes hey a bad movie could a good
movie it could be a great time but
that's sort of the fun of it right we
look at the number on Rotten Tomatoes
and then that starts to debate amongst
your friends you know you should never
use Rotten Tomatoes as to be all end-all
to see a movie but it should be used as
that like you said that conversation
point of did the critics get it right
did the fans get it right and how does
this affect like our movie going
experience so we just need less mean
critics and less stupid fans and then
we're all good right
stupid right now
I think I would like to make my own
opinion okay so you're not worried about
anybody else you're just out there for
you yep Barbie's independent so cool
well it turns out a lot of folks know a
lot about Rotten Tomatoes now it's your
turn comment with who do you trust the
Critics on the Tomato Meter or the
audience score thanks for tuning in to
on the street happy birthday Rotten
Tomatoes happy birthday to you happy
25th birthday Rotten Tomatoes you guys
rock
happy birthday Rotten Tomatoes happy
birthday Rotten Tomatoes happy birthday
Rotten Tomatoes happy birthday Rotten
Tomatoes happy birthday Rotten Tomatoes
happy birthday Rotten Tomatoes you're 25
you can rent a car now it's Rotten
Tomatoes birthday Penny you want to say
happy birthday say happy birthday
good to go REM dog I call him REM dog he
doesn't like it but I call him remdoc
shout outs to Jason Lee and Justin watch
my friends
do you think they're watching you right
now
um probably not